(BELL DINGS)
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Every time!
(BELLOWS) Welcome to
the World Texting Federation!
(CROWD CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
I, of course, am
Knuck F. Yoobuck!
The best and only WTF announcer!
Now, who's ready
to fight?
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
CONTINUES)
In this corner,
cries about Drake,
the overly emotional, Long Text!
She may be emotional,
but she's a tough competitor!
Oh, she's showing you
the text chain.
Read it and weep!
That's what she did.
Ah, she's got something to say.
(WHIMPERS) I won't--
I won't make this long, but...
(SOBS) ...since you won't answer
my calls,
-I have no choice--
-Too long didn't read!
Hey! Up next,
her first opponent...
is the text that's guaranteed
to piss you off.
Give it up for K!
(CROWD CHEERS)
CROWD: (CHANTING) K! K!
YOOBUCK: The drama.
The intrigue!
CROWD: (CHANTS) K!
You better add a fourth K.
CROWD: (YELLS) K!
K.
(CROWD CHEERS)
Oh, it's so simple!
And deceptive!
A woman of few words
and actually only one letter!
Ah! Next up on here tonight,
this is Long Text's partner.
She's highly anticipated
but supremely agonizing...
3 Dots
because your friend is typing!
3 DOTS: That's right.
(CROWD SIMMERS)
-(YELLS) Oh!
-(CROWD CHEERS)
(YELLS) Oh!
She's gonna keep us waiting
like an Uber on New Year's Eve.
Unbelievable.
She didn't have shit to say.
Now,
rounding out K's team.
Give it up for the one
that dings and then pings
in the dark...
Give it up
for 2AM What You Doing!
(CROWD CHEERS)
Oh! This is a grind session
in here, ladies and gentlemen.
♪ (R&B MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Peaches and eggplants
for everybody!
YOOBUCK: She's giving out
peaches and eggplants?
A classic 2AM move.
It's the produce for me.
Long Text, K, you're up first.
Now, I want a fair conversation
tonight.
So, turn on your read receipts
and reply in a timely fashion.
Now, bump thumbs, let's do this!
(BELL DINGS)
(CROWD CLAMORS)
(WHIMPERS) I know
that you're probably asleep,
but I can't stop thinking
about the things
that you said to me
five years ago at Sizzler!
K.
YOOBUCK: Oh, K hits Long Text
with a disinterested shrug!
Oh, she's gonna screenshot this,
and she's gonna send it
to her friends.
And analyze it with her friends
for weeks to come!
Oh, look at this!
We have our first tag in,
2AM WYD, and Three Dots,
both require more patience
than a Black kid waiting
to get picked up from school.
What you doin'?
Your parents are not coming,
they forgot about you!
Go!
Oh, 2AM WYD is down!
Now his strategy usually
requires him
to send multiple texts
and wait for responses.
Not gonna work here,
you can't bugaboo your way
outta this one!
(SCREAMS)
2AM: Tell me what!
YOOBUCK: Oh,
this is embarrassing!
Oh, 2AM!
You don't have the stamina
to finish!
You are embarrassing yourself,
2AM!
I've never had this problem.
Get him some Viagra.
-Oh!
-(CROWD CHEERS)
2AM is up!
Oh! 2AM is up! 2AM is up!
With the classic dick move.
What are you doin'?
-Oh!
-(CROWD CHEERS)
-One...
-Come on, girl.
I can see you're there,
just say something!
Two!
Long Text, you're gonna have
to get in there
if you're gonna do something.
Do it now!
Someone ain't listen!
-(GROANS)
-Three!
And with that,
2AM WYD and K
are the new WTF champions!
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
Oh, the evil Green Android
has entered the group chat.
-(CROWD BOOS)
-Yeah, boo! Yeah, boo!
What is there,
a bunch of newborns in here
the way you're
fuckin' crying?!
Boo all you want!
When you want a group photo,
you're gonna come crawling
to me!
Fuck are you gonna do
with that?
-(REACTION ALERT DINGS)
-YOOBUCK: Oh! Oh! Oh!
Oh, Green Android
couldn't handle a thumbs up.
Androids can't see those
kind of reacts!
She was totally defenseless
in the face
of advanced communication!
ALL: WTF! WTF! WTF! WTF!